[Music]  it's just different  every holiday they make it so beautiful  that you're in awe of it  yeah the flowers they're real it's so  beautiful  just love coming in here we have photos  every year of us  [Music]  we have a steadfast commitment to  keeping traditions alive for both our  local visitors and our out-of-towners  so we have our uh fan favorites of the  polar bears here we've got the mom and  the dead and the three babies frolicking  the fresh cut carnations we'll use we'll  go through about 70 000  stems of fresh cut carnations throughout  the show  it really contributes to the scent in  the room and they  take special attention to detail it's  just they  they put every bit of their hearts and  thought into it  and make it feel magical